thank you
[Music]
okay but uh does anybody here besides me
follow and watch moist critical on
YouTube
voice critical his name's Charlie
penguin zero penguin zero yeah he's a
he's a YouTuber name could uh streamer
really really great dude I love this guy
he recently got into some beef with a
guy named snico who was kind of like an
Andrew Tates he's like a red pill guy
yeah he's a red pill guy yeah do you
know uh Joe I think so guys I got this
they got this massive like internet beef
that I I cannot even what are you
rooting for oh dude Charlie 100 oh [__]
stupid what's his name Charlie moist
always critical it's about like the
clips and like yeah about the show yeah
yeah yeah yeah but uh yeah they got into
this [__] where like snico obviously has
a bunch of like hot takes about all
kinds of stupid stuff that you're like
okay I get it you're trying to you know
be a contrarian
um some things such as thinking that his
opinion that he really likes the Netflix
move uh show cuties
you know the one that was like a bunch
of little girls oh right dancing around
and he had some commentary that he
really liked it he also talked about how
every he thinks every guy with a
girlfriend should let another man like
[__] your girl
um that's what he thinks because that's
real alpha male [__] huh Alfie or some
[__] he thinks it's healthy to cook out
yeah yeah how is he a red pill guy if
you're saying that okay like if he
believes that I kind of like this guy
I'm kind of on board that's what you
think cool all right two for two so then
um
that hey wasn't the cutest movie it was
like about like like the the pageant
dancer girls
yeah and then people got mad because the
the the picture was like yo these are
like little kids yeah it's weird it's
like six-year-old girls picking up
quarters and [__] oh yeah it was wild
wild [__] trailer yeah so and he said
he was liking that he was like he made a
video saying that he actually liked it
and that people weren't understanding it
correctly or whatever what is that I
understand that's a weird sense so then
uh even Andrew tastes like I ain't
touching that one he's like huge
Andrew's like that's wrong man hey bro
you're Walling out dude that video Down
AKA Charlie he makes a commentary about
how he he doesn't respect his opinion
because it's you know messed up they get
all these back and forth things it's a
kind of semi-long thing but the best
part and the only part that I really
wanted to show you guys especially you
which I think you would appreciate
serious Nico gets kind of like irate
about him he has like this like sort of
like a [__] list on the side of his
screen when he's streaming that's talk
like showing the people that he doesn't
like that are being mean to him and
saying stuff about it those are girls
huh
oh God damn it so wait he he has a like
a list of people that he doesn't like
those people he doesn't like them
I like them
I want you guys to always see that I
don't like these it's pretty interesting
pretty interesting angle it doesn't make
it it's gonna look weird
all the time these are all the people
who own my brain yeah we're really
making a lot of stuff
real estate is split up and divided
amongst people how many like followers
does he have like does he have a pretty
big following like yeah it has I think
it's a decent because he's a streamer
too right sure yeah I think I mean he's
banned from YouTube yeah yeah he's not
on YouTube now because of his you know
but here's a clip of where he was uh
talking about Charlie and Charlie's like
narrating this as he's talking about it
but uh Charlie's response is is Charlie
on the list perfect yeah Charlie's right
here that's moist critical at the top oh
I've seen that dude that guy yeah oh I
didn't know that yeah I love that guy I
love him YouTube videos yes he does so
here we go down about the whole thing
and then he sent some of his viewers
over so I was joking with them saying
like oh you guys must have just stopped
the cuties watch party over there it's
Nico's stream right welcome Cox that
kind of [__] and it got really under his
skin in a big way so he started dancing
around with the gun and threatening to
come shoot me so he kept saying oh
you're in Tampa right I'll come see you
waving his gun around and dancing
you want to watch my Clips watch my
clips
watch my clips
you wanna you want me to watch your
Clips watch my Clips that's a magazine
bro
what's happening
now the reason he keeps saying is watch
my Clips while threatening me here is
because during the stream I couldn't
watch him live because he just kept
shouting slurs so I said watch my Clips
to see what I was saying about you I had
to communicate via twitch clips and I'm
sorry to be that guy this is like the
grammar police of guns but he's a
[__] imbecile you absolute buffoon
what you have there is not Cliffs these
are mags yeah they're mags you
absolutely
the same way that this is what a low-key
Flex three mag they're all mags stop
saying Clips you look [__] stupid
here anyway sorry for the gun Anatomy
lesson
that's a sick ass response man yo is
that crazy like nowadays it's like these
dudes are like kind of banging over like
it's like streaming right yeah showing
guns like oh I'm gonna come get you but
it's like it's hard [__] man
I'm not gonna lie these guys are [__]
tough dude like tough dudes
imagine like the old like Chicago mob
talking to people talking [__] to their
gang Rivals well they couldn't because
they probably couldn't figure out how to
how to get their camera to work
hey Vinnie you guys see me on this [__]
I can't I can't wait I can't [__]
hear you I can see your lips moving I
can't [__] hear you bro that's so
crazy that they're they're he's just
waving his gut is that legal it's not
legal but like can't you get your [__]
taken down for doing that yeah oh that's
cool
so like snico's infinitely said way more
stuff about Charlie like Charlie maybe
said one tiny thing and that was just
his opinion but then for months sunico's
been like mentioning Charlie and like
like he's obsessed with him and then
Charlie's just like dude like what and
then he'll make maybe like two videos
and it's just like really bothering
sneako a ton so it's funny how a lot of
these guys that are supposed to be Alpha
guys in the manosphere
are kind of not at all like they don't
have girlfriends like red pill dudes
yeah they're not
like they're not the people that they
they they say that you're supposed to
but Joe They Don't Need Girlfriends dude
yeah they got the boys in the chat
they've elevated themselves like past
that how many like followers does I mean
how many viewers does this guy get per
stream like roughly do you know you do
this just to mess with me no I'm just
curious like he's like just like like
sneako like how big is his audience bro
like you know what I mean
foreign
I'm sorry I'm sorry I shouldn't have
asked that I thought you knew
I don't know sneakers stats because I
mean he's like like he got a couple mil
right on uh on Twitch yeah it's just
like twice yeah
there's a lot
there's a whole like
it's a crazy audience behind all this
stuff
I don't know specifically his ignore me
I'm sorry I'll just shut I'll just shut
the [__] up dude I don't I don't even
see it anymore I'm sorry
I do this every video I don't see it
anywhere what's his horoscope you know
what month he was born is he Capricorn
rising and he's like I knew it he's a
Taurus he's a [__] Taurus crazy of
course that's some tourist [__] that
he's doing oh Gemini rising even worse
even [__] worse I don't I don't see
his stats we could call the Records
Office if you want and have his have his
birth certificate sent to us do you know
what state he lives in does that hinder
like something you really wanted to say
about it I was just curious like because
I'm just thinking about like his scope
and his reach over like it's good it's
big yeah he has a big reach yeah I think
so he's kind of like so like when when
Andrew Tate was receiving all that stuff
and they were like oh he's gonna get
when he got banned yeah like oh it's
almost like everyone who was a tape
follower kind of also gravitated to
snico in a way because it's like but I I
still don't think they're that similar
yeah like I think who do you think is
cooler I think Andrew Tate's like
significantly makes more sense than CEO
if you're a sneaker how do you respond
to that
you know what I would do I swear to God
okay what would you do I would take a
Men's Health Magazine like this is a
magazine you [__] idiot
[__] magazine you're [__] [__]
hey don't battle with Steve green dude
you look stupid I would do like 10
minutes of how he's a [__] idiot if
you're going through the pages
oh look here's another magazine wired
highlights [__]
highlights bro have you ever seen this
at the dental office there's a bunch of
really funny things too where like
there's another guy named Brandon
Buckingham who's a Creator and he's
called out sneako tons of times to fight
like like a fist fight that's wonderful
that's what they should do but then he
he sneako doesn't even put that guy on
that list like he purposely avoids him
because he knows that it's like it's he
knows it's real but he's Alpha though
that is Alpha that's very Alpha yeah
that is so Alpha a lot of weird things
but I mean ultimately you just look you
you definitely look Dumber though if
you're more mad first of all exactly and
if you're talking about it that much
more than like Charlie is like you so
bad you're waving a gun in the camera
yeah but a lot of these guys they don't
troll like um like Andrew Tate they um
they're just actually serious about
really seriously whereas Andrew Tate
says some crazy [__] that you know he
knows he's being he's stupid control it
seems like it's a big [__] joke yeah
yeah it's like what like 19. he seems
like the product of like people that
follow entertain that like in copy paste
literally yeah not that everyone who
falls out of shade is like a scumbag
it's just like this is an example of it
going bad I watch Andrew take the same
with the same I like when I see um Alex
Jones like I know it's a character and
they say outlandish [__] but sometimes
they believe their character too much
and then they don't know how to flip
back
though because he's kind of being like
prosecuted right now
we'll see if these girls yeah we'll see
if he's guilty but you know
some really good points I don't think
there's any good point to waving a gun
around on a stream I don't even know
what his position is but a lot of these
guys just like they just pair it what
other people say within that yeah it's
it's the contrarian mentality of like
let me just go radically against what
everybody's thinking so that it gets
attention and then some people get
addicted to that they're just like oh I
always have to find the thing that no
one wants to hear well because it gets
the clicks yeah it does it obviously
does like and it is interesting like I
will say because if you tell a a woman a
go make a sandwich or something people
go oh my God god oh my god well yeah
there are there is an audience for that
sadly yeah the side of the table right
here that's right what happened I
thought this was the red pill we got a
sense of humor too yeah we think we
think that's funny I make sandwiches
yeah we're cool we're cool with it dude
I went to a women's rights thing and I
had chicks there make you a sandwich we
did a sandwich making competition yeah
who won
um the women did because it was women
versus women but the point of it was not
haha aren't they so stupid it was
actually like that they're not as rigid
as you guys think that they are like
they could make sense they were laughing
and like having a good time and not
being like this is so [__] crazy how
can you [__] do this [__]
you know what I mean like but that's
probably what happened now yeah for
granted that eight years ago but still
it's like that was the point like it's
like these are nice people they're not
as they're not what you think they're
not the caricature that you think they
are actually like they're they're pretty
cool they're like just chill ladies that
you'd meet like at the store or
something hey man that's really cool did
anybody chill ladies that you meet in
the kitchen if they're sandwich making
no women I think know exactly how to
make a sandwich yeah they make a good
sandwich I don't think there's anything
wrong with it I think they're just born
knowing how to put those [__] two
slices of bread
so they were throwing down they were
thrown at you it's kind of like an
inherent genetic trait that you're born
with it's not it's generation yeah it's
like you get some bread
some mayo they just they just started
going I made a sandwich for my boyfriend
whoa hey that's cool you did I really
did and I I swear I'm not just making it
up yesterday I made him a sandwich and I
was like what do you say to me and he
was he like hesitated and he was like
thank you and I was like no say it and
he's like thanks [__]
nice there was a woman who was a she was
she came from Argentina right and she
just happened to be walking through the
crowd she's never made a sandwich before
they don't have sandwiches in Argentina
and I was like can you just make that no
we blind we blindfolded her and she
[__] just built it like it's like you
just know how to do it it's in our DNA
and when they're born I swear yeah it's
crazy damn
laughs
[Music]